Riyad mansur palestine's ambassador to
the UN is calling for a permanent
ceasefire in Gaza he says it's necessary
to save the Palestinian State for the
Israeli government the priority is not
security it is the destruction of the
Palestinian nation of the very presence
and existence of the Palestinian people
on their land of Palestinian statehood
the meeting of the UN General Assembly
was meant to take stock of where member
states stand on the Palestinian question
as a whole the un's overwhelming chorus
of disapproval of Israel's killing of
civilians in Gaza clearly angering
Israel's representative who pointed to
the general assembly's failure to
condemn
Hamas in the wake of hamas's October 7th
Massacre the un's Twisted anti-israel
bias has been on clear display for for
the world to see high stakes diplomacy
continues here on Wednesday when China's
foreign minister will chair a highlevel
security council meeting on the
situation in Gaza other foreign
ministers are also expected to attend
including perhaps the prime minister of
Qatar a country that has become the key
mediator in the conflict Gabriel zando
Al jaaz at the United Nations in New
York
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer